What's the biggest problem facing
New York, or London, or San Fransisco?
Many people would say
the high cost of housing.
As cities have become safer and
more economically successful,
they have also become more expensive.
Sky high real estate prices seem to be
turning many cities from places where
ordinary people can find a better future
to boutique towns that are affordable
only to the already prosperous.
The housing problem afflicts not
just the wealthiest cities, but
also some of the poorest ones as well.
Yes, living in Johannesburg is
cheaper than living in New York, but
the cost of housing can loom large to
an economically desperate South African.
When we think about creating
affordable housing,
we need to remember that we need
solutions for both Boston and Calcutta.
And those solutions
are unlikely to be the same.
The first question this section
asks is why is housing so
much more expensive is
some places than others?
Are high prices driven by robust demand,
or limited supply, or both?
And will the high housing prices that
we see in cities like Shanghai and
San Francisco persist?
Buying a house is often the biggest
financial decision that a person makes.
It seems sensible to think a bit
about what keeps prices high.
The second question is what should be
done to make cities more affordable?
Does the affordability require
rent control or housing vouchers?
Should we be subsidizing new construction
or adding units of public housing?
And who's gonna pay for all these parties?
Restricting the supply of the new
housing is never going to make housing
less expensive, but
that doesn't mean that government
shouldn't regulate new housing at all.
What if all the new buildings just seem
to be apartments for billionaires?
Should London restrict heights to preserve
sight lines at St Paul's cathedral?
Should Boston stop building to keep
shadows from falling on urban parks?
Should cities preserve old buildings
as a reminder of our urban past?
Too many great cities have
become too expensive.
We need to understand why and
what can be done about it.